i am quite interested in metagenomics
microbiology and um uh astronaut health
astrobiology all of those things
and i'll give a short introduction on
how i got interested in these things and
then i'll talk about my project that i
conducted during
my internship at
pine biotech
so um an overall is that my
research was based on the adverse
effects of high led radiation
on the mouse uh gut microbiome and
consequently on the nervous system
causing psychological disorders like
anxiety and depression
so why am i so interested in microbes
and it's because um when you think of
microbes we usually think pathogens but
that's
changing now we don't only think of
you know microbes that make us ill but
we also think of them as a treatment now
we can um help use the these microbes
using metagenomic studies to find
unconventional treatments for diseases
like cancer or atopic dermatitis
and also because it's obviously a core
of astrobiology studies and it's
essential in understanding evolution
because we
were
coexisting for all these years so we
cannot understand our own evolution
without the evolution of microbes
and of course as um dr gary and
as this has discussion touched upon it
in climate change and agriculture
studies and finding renewable resources
microbes are invaluable
so i chose this topic specifically astro
health because of the prospects of space
travel and how they advance therefore
the research involving space travel
increases proportionately so among
biology biotech and human research
conducted on the iss the international
space station
our studies on how humans and animals
are affected by space travel
which will be important for us in the
future
so it's a fast-paced and growing field
and my research specifically is on a
space type radiation called ionizing
radiation
and more specifically high led linear
energy transfer radiation
high led radiation can penetrate into
microstructures and has enough energy to
cause chemical change
lead which leads prominently to zelda
and according to the information
collected by the iss research the
effects of radiation exposure on human
health
are currently uncontrolled and will
continue to be so for the foreseeable
future
one promising factor however is that
host microorganism interactions will be
optimized to say the least by around
2028.
here's my methodology i had three main
stages which was data exploration
statistical analysis and then drawing
conclusions in the data exploration
stage i found my data set which was on
mousecut microbiota from ncbi and then
using the um tbi info platform i used
the data two pipeline and the phylloseq
pipeline on the dataset that i had which
was 16 as amplicons
to find
paths that could lead me
further into
understanding the data
so then i conducted anova and t test to
find if the
observations i made during the pilocy
stage were correct and then finally i
tried to connect
these results to
palpable
therapy ideas potential therapy ideas
so my data set was a total of 80 samples
and it was divided into two categories
one was based on radiation
going from zero point one point two five
and one gy radiation and the samples
were collected ten days post radiation
and 30 days cost radiation
and here is one of the outputs that i
got from the phyloseq pipeline which is
nmds non-metric multi-dimensional
scaling which helps us observe the whole
data set and
find um relative
connections between them or separations
and in this one we can see the relative
separation between the families of
bacteria found in those samples
collected from the gut microbiota
and here i observed from this angle that
10 days post radiation is more grouped
than 30 days post radiation
and then another up
output of the final seek pipeline was
the shannon index graph
and
the shannon index is a value used for
measuring the richness and evenness of
species in different samples
so from my comparison here i found that
between
the four different
radiation doses the shannon index
decreases with exposure to radiation at
lower doses than at higher doses and i
also during my research found out that
this is due to the properties of high
led radiation
and this is an excellent example that
summarizes my entire findings during the
pre the x-data exploration stage
and from here we can see from the
phylogenetic tree um that the otus that
are significant
that changed significantly from the
control group which was zero gy
and we can see that 0.1 um gy had lower
abundances compared to zero we can also
see that otu four and five have a common
ancestor in recent times
so this is one of the very most useful
graphs that came out of the file seek
pipeline that helped me
make
analytical observations and then i
decided to use statistical analysis
which was the anova and t-test
to make sure that my observations were
correct
and you can see from the simplified heat
map
that otu 3 4 5 and 8
were the significantly decreased ones
and i also came to the conclusion that
0.1 gui collected at 10 days post
radiation was a significant group and i
also found out that there was a
connection between the samples connected
collected at 10 days post radiation and
the
radiation dosages so there was no
relation between those two categories
and the most significantly decreased
ones were the ones that were exposed to
0.1 gy radiation
so from this uh i also came
came to the conclusion that the
abundances for lactobacillus life the
bacterium and aerosol pelotric bacteria
were the most significantly decreased
abundances
the ones i'll be focusing on however is
lactobacillus and bifidobacterium since
they contributed to the imbalance in the
nervous system through protein coding
genes that they have and these protein
coinding genes correspond to gaba
and gaba is a
gamma-aminobutyric acid which is the
chief inhibitory neurotransmitter in the
central nervous system and it is
generated by bifidobacterium and
lactobacillus too
therefore a decrease in these species of
bacteria can cause or enhance disorders
like depression and anxiety which are
very common in astronauts
and here you can see that there are two
pathways the gs and the gls through
which these bacteria affect gaba
so from all this we can conclude by
saying that lower doses of high elite
radiation have a greater effect on otu
abundance in this case it is 0.1 gui
and we can also surmise that
the acclimatization period is between 10
and 30 days since the samples collected
30 days post radiation did not pass the
significance threshold but we also have
to keep in mind that these mice were not
exposed to radiation
in the long term the way astronauts are
and some of my limitations were of
course
the difficulty of the taxonomic
profiling since 16s regions are quite
similar
for bacteria in the same genus
and then there is also the
technicalities of optimization and the
limited sample size was another issue
but all in all this was a good precursor
study from microbiata studies in space
and further research should include
synergistic effect of radiation and
microgravity together
and of course um
in this whole stage i couldn't i don't
know because i didn't have a
bioinformatics background i don't know
how i could have achieved this if i
hadn't come across pine biotech and the
tbi info platform because that greatly
helped me along with the advisors like
dr mohit elia and dr harpreet who helped
me throughout my research
so
here are my references and um thank you
for listening to me i hope this was
enjoyable
thank you so much dilara and that was an
amazing presentation and it's also it's
a pleasure to listen to you every time
well there would be one question that
we have in the chat and it would be
great if you could address it in brief
for example first of all what was the
duration of the study the samples that
were exposed to the radiation what was
the duration
and
finally if you could explain the results
again
uh and their final like the final
genetics that you got
and what those families usually you can
conclude from those families that you
can find yeah so um basically the
duration
uh was not specifically mentioned in the
article that i chose the samples from
but it mentioned that it was during one
day so it wasn't as long-term as
astronauts do and we have to consider in
animal studies of course like
um
you know we can use mice musculus as a
sample animal model but we cannot expose
it to as much radiation as humans
do are exposed to in states also
and i guess this was the phylogenetic
one that you would like me to explain so
basically
when you run your samples through the
phyllo seeking data 2 pipeline
they go through all the usual stages
like normalization and you know your
samples are cleaned etc
uh and then
this is the output that you get and from
this you can here um understand
that um
1.1.25 and zero
i don't know if you if i enlarge it if
you can see it more clearly
um
but from this you can tell the
abundances of o2s and o2s are
operational taxonomic units when you run
the data two pipeline and the financing
pipeline together you don't um
exactly get
uh all of the
genus and species names of the bacteria
that are uh in the sample first of all
because um there are a lot of dna
samples that are not titled that are not
named
and then they're also the fact that um
when you run these uh these dna samples
are very volatile and they break a lot
so uh you know estimations have to be
made and um the system basically when
you're in the pipeline we'll align the
dna samples
that are present in
these microbiota ecosamples as much as
possible
and then it will not give it a name
it will not first it want to run it
through the
databases and say like this is like the
best routes or this by the bacterium the
first thing you get is operational
taxonomic unit
which is similar to saying this is one
type of bacteria but it's not
specifically named so that's what otu
means here that's what the otus are
and then you what you get is um these
correspondences you know otu4 is and
otu5 is by for the bacterium genus and
etc and the you don't usually get down
to um the species name if you don't
optimize it too much
because um
of the limitations as i said of
the you know the numerous types of
bacteria that are still not sample named
or sampled you know they're not in the
database of these dna samples so they're
usually left down to the genus name so
that's why um how that's how i made the
correlation between otu and uh
the bifidobacterium and lactobacillus
basically i took out what was in the
um final seek pipeline what this gave me
as a correspondence you know it gave me
bifidobacterium and lactobacillus and
then i ran it again on the jgi pipe you
know database and i found the genus and
species name together which are these
ones
that's great and biology yeah yeah and
is there a correlation between the
abundances that you found and the
neurological activity with gaba that you
mentioned
yeah so basically um because i was using
samples that were previously um
you know collected by other researchers
this was like a totally bioinformatic
study i couldn't exactly go back and
analyze the uh behavior of mice so i
couldn't conclusively say
that
this decrease affects the nervous system
i can't say that because i don't i
didn't work with those mice basically
but what i can do is run through again
the jgi pipeline and find that these
um bacteria
have protein coding genes for sure that
affect the human nervous system they um
basically through the
um central nervous system
and through the um
enterodenderitic nerve which is the
nerve that goes through your gut
and collects these chemicals and it
affects your central nervous system in
return
so in theoretically i can say that a
decrease in the abundances
will cause anxiety and depression
because gaba
conclusively decreases so that's what i